[Music]
[Music]
oh what a lad well i've had plenty of
requests from all of you to hear from
some other champion lads from other
sports so here i have an absolute treat
for you today's guest is currently the
best tennis player in the country and at
only 23 years old he is the future of
the game he is an incredible talent he
also happens to be one of the best lads
going around so i'm really looking
forward to this one it is the lad
himself ajit rai welcome lad
hey those are the most compliments i've
ever had in like the space of 20 seconds
i feel pretty good
appreciate you for having me on bro mate
you're a lad and i'm looking forward to
hearing a little bit more about the
tennis game
something that i've followed but and
played casually but never really known
the ins and outs of the game but um who
better than yourself to give us the
rundown yeah
it's it's it's a journey that's for sure
um yeah i'm just excited to kind of
share my journey
um with you and i think uh kind of dig
deep in into what it's really like on
tour not just the glitz and the glam off
traveling to different countries and you
know it's there's a lot more that goes
into it than uh
just the tennis match itself yeah from a
distance it looks like the sort of dream
lifestyle they get to travel the world
you get to play in these hissing
tournaments but i could imagine after a
while that can get pretty old and
some of the tournaments especially i
guess where you're at at the moment the
grind to get up to these um big
tournaments it must be pretty tough
yeah i mean i i don't think people
realize that you lose more than you win
every year so
it's it's like losing in a country and
then traveling to another country is
like
you know even if even if you win it's
great but you know
the kind of thing i realize is you only
have like
four or five hours to enjoy your win and
then refocus for the next match which is
the next morning yeah so it's the highs
are awesome but they don't last very
long so
you got to quickly switch around and you
know do your recovery and get ready for
the next match
next morning but
i'm very grateful to be able to do what
i do but it's it's a challenge and just
when you think you're starting to figure
things out a new challenge comes your
way so
it's um
it's it's exciting to be honest so
yeah mate it's awesome looking forward
to hearing a little bit more and i'm
keen to hear it from the start as well
so obviously um to get into tennis and
be good at tennis i'm guessing you have
to get into it pretty young um how did
it all start for you
yeah so
i was around probably three years old
when my old man put a tennis racket into
my hand um he's so my dad's a tennis
coach and um
he uh you know used to take me down to
the tennis courts and stuff i played all
sports growing up except rugby because
i'm indian um and skinny so it doesn't
doesn't really work um
but i i played you know soccer golf
cricket did the triathlons all of that
stuff tried to play basketball but that
didn't end well um
but
yeah from a young age he just put a
tennis racket in my hand and it was kind
of the way i got to spend time with him
um my brother was a really good tennis
player as well he's six years older
and it was just a way of spending time
with my you know my older brother and my
dad uh mum and sister not into on
twitter i don't think mum mum doesn't
even watch me play if she watches me
you know in new zealand it's on tv she
doesn't watch any of my matches she like
gets stressed and you know so she
doesn't watch it at all but yeah it was
just kind of a connection to my dad so
at three years old started playing and
then at six years old
my dad started taking me to australia to
a coach called peter mccraw who had
uh he was the coach at boleteria academy
he was the head coach there coach maria
sharapova and
he took me over there and my dad and
peter kind of developed me and every six
weeks i'll go to australia for two weeks
to see him and this is at like six years
old so that's crazy
yeah it's very young um and then you
know eight years old nine started
playing the nationals and stuff like
that and just started enjoying it more
and more but
um
yeah it was more just a way to spend
time with my dad because he was of
course my coach and he was always at the
courts from three o'clock you know after
school till 8 o'clock in the evening so
i just wanted to go down there and hit
tennis balls and just ended up getting
better and better at it i mean it's
there would be something wrong if i
wasn't getting better and better at
spending the whole day at the tennis
court
so at a young age it was just like just
a great feeling to be on tennis court
and i honestly haven't lost that feeling
since so even now if i go to the courts
i feel like i'm a five-year-old kid just
going to the tennis courts i love it so
um you know like a lot of people have
asked me do you still enjoy it and
you know my mum and dad have said to me
as soon as you stop enjoying it we want
you to stop we don't want you to keep
playing if you don't enjoy it
and
yeah i just love it bro so
that's kind of how it all started for me
and still went to school and whatnot um
and then went to new plymouth boys high
and kind of started doing more home
school and that type of thing there i
think my attendance for one year because
i was traveling was like three days
so um
yeah they they actually brought it up
when i went back there like a year ago
and they're like you know your
attendance was three days for one year
like that's without getting like
suspended or expelled that's the lowest
attendance we've ever had i'm like yeah
and those three days were the days like
we would have tennis matches so yeah i
would just turn up to play those but i
was just you know
in juniors i traveled for like
australian open and junior wimbledon and
junior us open so
um it was just
it there's never the season never really
ends in tennis it's like it goes from
january all the way through to december
you can pick and choose when you play
but
you know you just got to keep playing
otherwise the rest of the competition
keeps going
yeah so what age of those
junior opens what age can you start
under 18 years
under 18. any age
you've got to be 13
um
so that's 13 to 18. so i won my first
doubles when i was
14 my first
under 18s title international when i was
14 which was quite young
and then i won my first singles
um when i was 15 or 16. i won my first
singles title
in
hamilton out of all places
it was in hamilton yeah
so um
yeah that's where it all came about and
then i did well at juniors i was maybe
ranked like 50 or 60 in the world
under 18s and then started kicking on to
play internationally
so were you clearly dominant in the new
zealand age groups because obviously new
zealand probably not a well-renowned
tennis country are we so were you like
clearly the best in the country
i don't want to say like clear we had a
lot of good players we had a lot of good
players um
but
yeah i i think um
there was you know myself and a couple
others who
played on the world stage and
internationally and i
was fortunate enough to get my ranking
up to number one
from 12s 14s 16s 18s and mins so
um
yeah new zealand we're lucky we have
guys like mike venus and marcus daniel
and reuben statham and artem sea tech
guys who have put
you know new zealand on the map we also
do have cameron nori who's a kiwi and
he's been top 10 in the world um
and ben mclaughlin so we've actually
there is a lot of players in new zealand
who have been
pretty dominant in the world
but they play for a different flag
so they they
they jump [ __ ] um but they're kiwis in
my box so do they have to jump [ __ ] why
why they why do they jump ship like that
um
without getting in trouble um
it's just funding they just get funding
other countries have more money and they
just get funding
from other countries and more
opportunity so
you know if you're gonna get wild cards
into wimbledon
you would jump [ __ ] you know like it's
gonna
jump start that it's gonna give you a
huge boost and at a young age if you can
get those wild cards it's massive
is it something you've looked into or
think are thinking about doing do you
have to do it personally no because i
grew up in taranaki and i just feel
everything i know is taranaki in new
zealand and i don't think any one of my
mates would ever talk to me again if i
did so
i just personally wouldn't uh wouldn't
do it i'm
you know patriotic so
about
where i come from
um
so
yeah i don't i don't think i ever would
but everyone has their own choice and
they do what's best for them um that's
cool so you were you were born in new
plymouth were your parents where were
your parents from so mum and dad both
indian dad was actually born in africa
and uganda out of all places
um so that's actually where i went to
play my first
international tournament when i was 18.
and uh
he
actually got 10 times more attention
than i did there like it was like some
hero had returned like
my dad was just laughing at our bags
like he would be in the hotel and he'll
be like warm up i'll be like have a
match at 11 i'll be like warm up at 10
because you know you've got to play in
the warm-ups oh we'll have to make it
nine because i've got an interview at
10. i'm like what do you have an
interview boys like yeah they're
welcoming home you know i'm coming back
to my roots
all right mate you do you um and then
yeah i was born in uh new plymouth and
my brother and sister were born in
stratford
so
yeah i'm a taranaki man nice so was your
dad a tennis player or he was a tennis
player but then when he wanted to turn
pro
it's such a financially expensive sport
my grandfather was like no go to uni so
my dad became an accountant and
mum's a psychologist and
just had to go study whereas when i had
the same opportunity i was fortunate
enough that my parents backed me and you
know they haven't really looked back
since so i've been pretty lucky yeah
that's awesome so when you mentioned
like you hardly attended school because
all these tournaments so what was yeah
what was your like teenage years like
obviously
um you've got tournaments you're pretty
you're pretty flat out you're probably
training 24 7.
yeah it was
at the time i struggled with that part a
lot because
being in taranaki it's not
a very tennis environment it's not a
high performance you know for tennis
environment
new zealand it's it's tough in new
zealand to find that environment
so you know i didn't
have a drop of alcohol until i was you
know 20 21 years old i
didn't really go to parties i didn't
really do any of that it was train in
the morning go to school my dad would
pick me up at lunch train at lunch and
train after school
so
it was literally just full on all the
time um
i'm
i look back at it now and i'm very
grateful but it was also very very tough
at the time
so
uh
you don't have much of a childhood but
it's a sacrifice you've got to make and
i didn't really understand it at the
time but
i'm grateful for it now so did you have
much of a like did you have many friends
and stuff or was it hard to sort of keep
on top keep in touch with friends and
stuff
ah i
i mean
yeah
i have a pretty tight unit like my best
mate this guy from taran decker his name
is cole hareb um and he's been my best
mate since i was you know like two three
years old um
and you know i have my close mates who i
play golf with and i get along with
really well but
you know your your best mate's kind it's
a lonely sport man tennis like you're
traveling by yourself or a lot of the
time
you win you lose you're you're by
yourself or like
your best friend literally is yourself
as sad as that sounds you got to be okay
with being a loner like that's that's
kind of how it is so you know i
you know i love being around my mates
but i also don't mind being by myself
either yeah so
yeah it's
uh you it's
that's the tough part like when we go
away for davis cup and stuff it's such a
sick week because you're around like a
bunch of guys who all have the same goal
whereas even at tournaments you know you
have a bunch of mates all my closest
mates are on tour
but you're trying to beat each other and
then you have to be okay with having
dinner with each other it's like
you know you're kind of like stealing
money from the other guy so
it's it's a bit
it's about it's a weird one but you just
gotta
kind of have that boundary of being a
tennis player and being a person
interesting and by all accounts i've
heard a yarn around you um burning down
one of your mates house so i'm sure that
didn't help your
friend's friend's base grow
on this one
the worst thing is so
it's one of my best mates his dad is
actually my sponsor so he's
been my financial sponsor for like a
long time
and uh
so it's like the parents sit us down and
they're like look we're going away to
taupo um to our batch or whatever um
we don't want you guys having a party or
anything no one's really like the house
cause their house is like prime real
estate right on the beach it looks over
the ocean it's like a mint house like
it's got a deck it's got everything the
surfboards like it's it's very very nice
so as soon as they leave i look at my
best mate
i won't name ho and i'm like
sweet so we're having like he's like
we're having a party right yeah
absolutely like they've told us not to
so we're doing it so you know just a few
people come around
and we're out all my mates are surfing
i'm in the barrel with my boogie board
and my flippers because i can't surf and
uh just enjoy myself
and um
then they're like having you know
they're smoking darts and stuff
afterwards not me because you know i
meant to be the athlete and whatnot so
i'm like kind of looking after the house
i'm like sweet i'll lock up all of this
stuff
and then
there was some outdoor lounge like
chairs you know the ones that are like
uh like outdoor furniture yeah and
they're smoking and they're like
throwing cigarettes and a box of beers
like putting them out and throwing them
okay sweet like and then a couple
must have fell through the cracks off
the deck and
they go to town and i've like
wanted everyone to leave i quickly
dropped town because the aussie open
finals on so i go back to my house to
watch the aussie open final
and then
and then about like two hours later one
of my other mates who lives on the road
messages me and he's like
hey there's eight fire engines outside
this your other mate's house and i'm
like nah you're taking the piss like i
left there like two hours ago like we're
met in the third set djokovic is about
to break like i'm not leaving like this
is like i'm parked up for the night i'm
good
so then he i'm like send me a photo
because i'm like this is you're yawning
yeah
sends me a photo there's eight fire
engines so i quickly wake up my old man
and i'm like because he's good friends
also with my best mates dad so i'm like
i need if this is true i need protection
because otherwise
i've lost my funding i've lost
everything like i'm basically going to
be homeless and
we go over there there's eight fire
engines and uh
my best mate
he's running back from town like not in
the best state of mind he's just
sprinting back from town
and um
we go down the whole deck is just gone
it's gone so
there was a fire underneath the deck and
it hit the barbecue and exploded at four
in the morning
and the whole house caught on fire and
the double glazing windows the first
glazing like cracked and then the second
glazing and the whole deck is gone and
me and
i mean he comes up he's like what a
great night though huh what a great no i
was like are you joking mate you just
burnt down your house like this is
unbelievable so
the parents um i mean they got insurance
so technically you know it's actually
good they should be thanking us they've
got an unreal house now and it's all
it's all well and good but
yeah it's fair to say we weren't allowed
back at the house for a wee while
after that uh they they handled it
pretty well but
i mean like when people say like don't
burn the house down and then you
actually do burn a house down it's like
yeah that was probably one of the worst
moments um
yeah that was pretty bad
oh i could imagine that feeling when you
foresee the house on fire just feeling
sick yeah i was just like what's the
chunk what are the chances of what are
the chances of that actually happening
it was yeah it was it was a nightmare it
was it was not good oh but you've still
got your funding
yeah i'm still i'm still i'm still back
somehow uh no he's a legend he's just
very close like he's like another dad to
me um and i'm just lucky i have support
like that because tennis is an expensive
sport yeah and um it's you definitely
gotta have money to play it otherwise it
just it's too hard you know
um you get injured you don't have income
that's how it is
you know whereas i look at some of the
other sports and guys get injured and
they still get income it's like man i'd
be rolling an ankle every second week
i'd be parking up on the sideline
but uh yeah it is it is what it is yeah
oh true so when did you think that um
you could potentially go pro at this
game so i was 19 and i went on to like a
it's like the atp tour so it's the
senior tour where you get atp points and
there's the futures challenges and the
grand slams and all of that so this is
like
you know
the futures which is pretty big
tournaments it's kind of like you need a
if you can't you know you need to start
winning those to even get to grand slams
and stuff it's like pro pro events yeah
and i went when i was 18 and played two
of them or 19 in thailand and first week
i lost first round and i was like okay i
played all right and then
the next week you know i was playing
number one seed he was about 200 in the
world or 210 in the world
ended up
beating him and ended up winning that
tournament just out of nowhere like i
got a wild card into the tournament
ended up winning it and
at that point i was kind of like
i didn't i never even dreamed of
you know new zealand was kind of
when you're number one in new zealand or
you're trying to be noble i wasn't even
number one at that time i don't think i
was top five or six i was
um
and then i won that tournament i was
like man i should give this like a go
and my parents were like you know
this is unreal and probably the most
unreal thing there was i was with my dad
and like
you know you do everything with your dad
you do a lot of hours with your dad
you're six am 6 am on court with him you
you know i mean the amount of fights me
and my dad have had and then my mom has
to mediate and you know like he like we
would have some brutal fights on tour i
mean it's tough to separate the two yeah
um
and to have him there and win my first
international title that was awesome so
that's when i decided like man i'm going
to give this a give this a crack and
it's you know i just want to go all the
way i want to be top 100 top 50 top 10
world number one i want to do it all so
um
that's my goal and i think
playing pro you shouldn't
well not shut it but i don't even know
what's the point playing if you don't
have those goals to be world number one
yeah you've got to aim for the top
100
love that so when you were 19 years old
playing against the number one seed in
the competition
how do you feel going into that game do
you feel confident or are you like [ __ ]
i'm gonna get pumped here i just had no
fear
i mean all those matches like playing at
the asb classic playing you know um
all these matches when i was younger i
was just like i don't want to lose love
and love yeah i just like i want my mum
to check the score and know i've got two
or three games like i want her to like
don't say come back you're going to
school or going to uni like
i was just like put on a good show like
um
but then at 19
i got the call up for davis cup which
was probably the most unbelievable
feeling like i was in my room and
in jakarta about to play uh
quarterfinals there so i was doing well
that week
qualified and beat two really good
players and
the davis cup captain calls me he's like
we want you on the davis cup team and i
remember my brother
was traveling with me that week and i
called my mom and mum was like no you're
joking you wouldn't make the davis cup
team
and i was like wow i got the call like i
don't like i'm pr like it was the most
exciting time of my of my career because
you know davis cup you watch it that's
as a tennis player uh maybe people don't
play tennis won't appreciate it it's
like being an all black for rugby
players that's that's the pinnacle for
someone growing up in new zealand and
then playing grand slams and
you know we get to korea
and i'm sitting in the changing room and
i got the call up to play doubles
because marcus hurt his back and i was
just there like you know i
i was the heading partner so i was like
kind of on holiday i was kind of
enjoying myself like tennis new zealand
were paying i was kind of eating well
you know enjoying myself and then
the coaches you know
they came up to my room to come tell me
i was selected and i had like a
frappuccino from starbucks and like a
custard bun
and they had told me at the start of the
week like they're going to be watching
what i eat in my professionalism
and i have this like massive thing with
caramel on it and i'm like so excited
i'm going to my room go watch some
netflix like the boys can play their
matches
and i get out of the elevator and one of
them's like you're meant to be playing
tomorrow but now we're reconsidering the
selection and i might play and this is
the coach saying this he's like i might
have to step and i was like
you can have that you can have that it's
all good sorry never going to happen
again and um
the next day i'm sitting in the changing
room and there's
marcus daniel michael venus artem sea
tech reuben statham
and i was like
kind of being like a deja vu because
when i was eight years old i was their
bull kid oh true and i was sitting in
the changing room asking them for
autographs yeah
and i'm like
either this is really exciting for me or
you guys are extremely old like how old
are you guys
and they were like pretty offended by it
but i was like this is weird like
i'm i was eight years old and now i'm
playing with you guys as a team and
you're on the sideline and you have
these guys supporting you and it's like
that's kind of that's the exciting thing
about tennis is you can really like
um
you can improve quick and get
results like some really sick results
pretty quick but also like the hard work
when you focus on the hard work and it
pays off it's so rewarding so how's
doubles how's doubles compared to
singles is it like
is it a hard adjustment
i
i play pretty good doubles like i've won
maybe like nine international titles
men's on the doubles side but i
don't enjoy it as much as singles but
it's freakish like the reflexes and
you know you have small targets to hit
into it's like
like mike and those guys when they're
like falling with you you just need a
helmet like they
just want to take your head off you know
like i i just like
it's it's just a different game i mean i
with all due respect i wouldn't say you
need as much fitness playing doubles
it's not as brutal as singles clearly
you're only covering half the core
but there's also a lot of thinking
involved i mean there's not many rallies
and doubles because it's all about
pre-established tactics and that type of
stuff
so it's tough i find it really tough
doubles so when you're called into that
doubles team late is that really hard to
just jump in there and play with someone
you haven't really played with before oh
i missed my first 13 returns i didn't
hit a ball i was hitting the back fence
and the coach is looking at me like
scratching his head and looking at the
manager they're like they've made a
mistake here like i honestly was so
excited i like because we're playing
against like
we're playing against like
two guys who are top 100 in the world
like they were playing aussie open and
they see this like little skinny indian
could come and they're like yeah boys
here we go that's two one up like that's
easy dub
and
i go in there and i'm like you know what
i'm gonna like hit laser beams i'm gonna
show these guys like who who i am like
i come out they're heading like cover
drives to the back fence like it was so
bad and like i look over the side and
everyone's just like scratching their
heads they're like this is real ugly i'm
so happy it wasn't televised and um
we ended up actually winning i like
actually ended up playing real well and
like artem c tech was unbelievable with
me like when i was missing he's like ah
it's all good i was like well it's
actually not
like this is really bad i'm sorry but we
actually ended up winning and playing
like really really well and those guys
it just shows like
mike and
reuben and artem and marcus like it's
not about the tennis but the leaders
they are is people like
that shows and shows me what i need to
aim towards it's not just about me
becoming a better tennis web also
helping the next generation coming up
and aspiring and the next generation
coming up and i'm lucky to have people
around me that
uh you know mentor me and help me out
and stuff like that
and you mentioned a little bit of court
banter
there is that quite common are guys
usually giving you a little bit of lip
oh brutal like
man
there was this argentinian dude last
year i won't name him but
anyone if any of my mates are listening
they know exactly who it is and like
this happens a lot like i'm also like
if anyone i'm not gonna say i'm i get
into it like i love like getting into it
on court as well
and
i'm playing this guy he's like 200 in
the world he's a great player very good
player like he's won a lot of big
tournaments this year and
i'm like six five up in the third set i
played a good first set lost a second
hit six five up and
i walk past him and he's like
says something about my mum like about
my mum like he keeps saying it
and i'm like
i looked at him and i'm like what did
you say he's like i said you're playing
really well
so he like because the umpire like that
like man these guys just they get so
personal yeah like
i was playing in new zealand here and
like a guy starts saying like at davis
cup like go back to your own country
well
i've got new zealand on my back like
i actually honestly i like yeah and like
even last year like guys would say like
go back to your own country and stuff
like honestly i do but quarantine like i
want to go back home like i really do
like you're not wrong but guys just i
mean they'll do anything to win but we
all will but yeah i mean guys will take
like
you'll be serving for the match and
they'll take a medical timeout they'll
say oh my knee's hurting i need three
minutes treatment so then they break
your rhythm it'll be like five four up
they'll be like i need to go toilet
sorry mate
gotta go they'll just walk off the core
you know they'll start like it's such a
mental game but like
probably the only thing i do
is like if someone's playing really well
i just let them know they're playing
really well i'm like man you're serving
unbelievable this is such good tennis
and then they start thinking they're
playing like good tennis
so then they're like start over you know
analyzing it
but i mean it's that's the part i've
learned to enjoy is like the mental
battles you have with people on the
court like
you look for anything like if you know i
remember i used to say when i was a kid
when i'd miss a four and i'm like i
couldn't hit a forehand
like imagine how dumb that is telling
your opponent you can't hit a forehand
like like how absurd is that like
imagine playing someone and they're like
i can't hit a forehand what are they
gonna do yeah they're literally just
gonna feed you balls to your forehead
so like
this part of tennis i'm starting to
enjoy and i've learned to enjoy it i
never did but i've learned to enjoy it
and now i just love going in for a
battle and i love like coming out of it
and being like man i left it all out
there that's the you know just applying
yourself and giving it your all so when
do you say that stuff is it when you're
switching ends or do you just call it
out after a good serve you just yeah i
mean a lot of the guys say it because
the umpire can't hear it because they're
finding people left right and center
like it's 100 fine 500 fine like they
just find you like crazy like you can't
even say the f word on court anymore you
get fined because everything's mic'd up
and then you know you go to a club rugby
game and you hear these guys like some
of the stuff they say it's like man i'd
be like done for 12 months if i said
some of that stuff you know
so
uh you just got to be very careful and i
wouldn't i mean just play tennis i'd
advise just to play tennis but when
you're playing especially
like
you know country say i'll say like the
south americans they
you know they're
ballers and they will do anything to win
like they will fake an injury and then
when you think they're going to retire
they'll come to the net to shake hands
like they're going to retire they'll
like do a u-turn go back and they'll
play unbelievable
so
yeah it's like it's just mentally like
sometimes just draining yeah it's just
draining man it is such a mental game
though isn't it so how much do you how
much time do you spend on like the
mental side of the game or is it
something you find quite hard to sort of
train no that's one thing you know i
used to train so much physically and so
much on my tennis and i got to a level
where i just felt like last year i was
at a standstill and just couldn't
improve and then
from december i started working
full-time with a psychologist and
um that has helped me incredibly i'm
working with him every day talking to
him every day whether it's good or bad
and
i've
benefited a lot from it i'm lucky to
have people around me again who help me
a lot with the mental side and people i
can lean on and other athletes i can
lean on
and
yeah i think it's very important to have
a good support team also because as much
as it is individual sport you got to
have people around you that can
help you you know what sort of stuff do
you guys talk about or what sort of
tips does he give you uh
more focusing like say on the process on
things i can control that's probably
been the biggest biggest thing for me is
focusing on stuff i can control i'm very
uh if anyone knows my massive
overthinker and you know i try to
control things i can't control like i
used to go into matches what if i lose
what if this happens what if that
happens
what's my dad going to think if i lose
what what about sponsors what that's
just irrelevant and it got to a point in
december january where i was like this
is just draining like it's super
draining to think like that
and
i just ended up changing it into you
know having my processes what i can
focus on and what i can control and i'm
a much happier person and i enjoy my
tennis and tennis is now what i do not
who i am so
um
i'm pretty lucky i guess i figured that
out a bit earlier but i did wish i
figured it out when i was
you know 16 playing in taranaki club
champs and not freaking out about
whose name was going to go on the honors
board so
yeah wait i love that
so when you're so when you're going into
a tournament or like heading into that
game what are your nerves like here
would you be for your first serve in the
match are you are you nervous are you
shaky or you're always usually pretty
confident horrendous
i mean i'm confident in myself i feel
i'm a confident person but
i'm i normally struggle to sleep the
night before i normally get pretty
broken sleep
um
and then
during the match i'm fine but it's like
before the match the build up it's like
your stomach is like
twisting and turning and you can't stop
moving and you know you're playing music
and you're trying to calm yourself down
i remember playing
my like first davis cup match a couple
years ago in new zealand i was playing
at the asb syndrome the first time like
my mom's watching me play in a long time
so i'm like man i wanted to think i'm
good like
she's like i wanted to think i'm like i
don't really care about anyone else but
my mom i want her to be like yeah my
son's a beast like this is pretty cool
and i remember the warm-up i was like
has someone like put this net up the
foot or two like the net felt so high
like i missed like the first six or
seven balls in the net and i'm just like
okay this is not good
this doesn't go but i ended up playing
pretty well and
whatever but nerves man like
since i've start like i start doing
sprints and stuff before to swear and
get my heart rate up but it's just
because i care so much um
but nerves
yeah nerves are just
i learned to enjoy them like i've come
back for the last couple weeks in new
zealand
and you know i was in thailand and i
played quite well there and
going you know deep each week in the
tournament and um i came back home and i
thought i needed a rest and i got back
home and i'm like
it's so boring like it's so boring not
competing like i want that excitement of
like
will you win will you lose like living
on the edge figuring out a plan for a
different player each day like analyzing
their game like
waking up in the morning not knowing if
you're gonna play good or bad but like
managing what you got on the day you
know like that's the exciting part about
tennis is it's not consistent it's like
something different each day you
mentioned analyzing there how much
analyzing do you have to do
my coach does it most of the time um so
like when i grew up playing tennis
people would ask me tactics i honestly
just saw where a person wasn't and hit
the ball into that corner yeah like it
was pretty simple but now you see like
different swing lines a guy might have a
more extreme grip so he can't hit a
certain shot guys play further behind
the bass line so you need to cut the
angles off and make the chord spoiler
for them you've got to put pressure on
their game so they feel a different way
so there's so much like
you know
there's different tactics for each
player you play lefty one day you play
righty next day the next day someone's
six foot four and has a big serve the
next day someone's five foot three and
runs at the back fence it's you just
gotta like
it's gotta be different every day and i
think that's the part people don't see
as they see
like that the match itself but they
don't see the tactics that are used and
like they don't see how much planning
goes into one match
interesting and i've one thing i've
always wondered about you see the
rallies or the walmarts when you're both
out on court
um i always find that quite a must be
quite awkward because obviously you want
to you're trying to like warm up the guy
you're just trying to be it seems weird
to me but what's it actually like this
is weird but i try to be like
kind of nice to the guy in the warm up
because i don't want him to be like a
dick during the match so i don't want to
have like a angry match but you can
notice in the warm up like
if these guys like a couple times like a
guy's head smashes i've given him
smashes and he's just trying to like peg
me he's like trying to hit me off the
smash
i'm literally giving you a smash like
it's not even the match yet you know and
it's like
one time i was playing like the umpire
did the toss last year and
i was like uh
heads so i win the toss and i'm like
i'll serve and i'm like oh good luck
mate he's like yeah you'll need it
okay i think i will yeah you're right
cheers appreciate that so you like
i mean the warm it's not really awkward
and you know most of the guys on tour
you're playing against now so like
you're pretty good mates with them and
you practice with them like there's a
lot of times that the draw's not because
the draw comes out on say sunday so on
sunday morning i practice with this guy
the draw comes out you're playing in the
next day yeah so you just practice with
it that's like it is it is awkward but
it also it is what it is yeah that's the
that's the tough thing about it
individual sport it's not like
in a team sport where you can warm up
with your team or yeah you know like
imagine a soccer team going and having
passes to each other before they played
match like they'd be so random but and
tennis i guess that's just how it is
yeah interesting and uh you've spoken a
little bit about the travel and how much
travel you get to do or have to do um
who organizes that have you got like a
manager or is that what your coach does
or how much of it falls on you
oh nothing i'm pretty lucky i have
people around me
if i like i tried to book a flight um
to train from new plymouth to auckland
and i'm like to my parents i'm like yeah
i'm going to auckland like i'm going to
train my flight's at 6 30 and my mom
travels a lot for work she's like
there's not a 6 30 flight leaving from
newport auckland yeah there is like drop
me at the airport i'm good and i get
there and i go to check in and it says i
actually booked the flight from auckland
to new plymouth not new punk to auckland
so this is a domestic ticket like i
can't even organize that so now i'm
pretty lucky i have people around me
that sort all that stuff out in my
travel and whatnot and they who travels
with you so sometimes i might travel
with a coach and stuff my dad used to
travel with me all the time my dad was
my he's been my coach he developed me
the whole uh the whole thing so he
traveled me a lot but um from last year
you know he's he's back home with mum i
think he's been happier traveling not
traveling with me anymore um
and yeah i travel by myself a lot you
meet up with players and stuff at other
tournaments but i'll start to travel
with a coach and stuff like that and
just makes it easier
so who's you who have you got a new
coach now or is your old man still
taking it yeah no so i'm working with a
coach and i mean my dad's always going
to be my coach he's always going to he
calls the shots he's you know the big
baller shot caller type of guy so um he
calls everything from home but uh my
coach right now is a guy called
christian grow he's in san diego and
he's coach tommy haas he's coach grigor
dimitrov taylor fritz quarter
um got asked to work with like djokovic
he's you know worked with the best
coaches and he's old-school german like
he is one of the toughest
guys to be on court with um
like we'll be warming up in the morning
and you know you're just warming up for
like 10 minutes but it's like intense
like not missing
and i'll miss like the first boy's like
he'll stop you
vegeta you okay today
what's going on this is like the first
ball i'll miss it
what's going on he's like if you're
gonna mess like then you're gonna you're
gonna act like this you can just get off
the court
i'm like okay sorry man so
i like wake up more nervous to train
with him than actually play a match
because i'm like man if this guy when
he's angry he's like tough but it's
exactly what i need right now too you
know like
he's very intense he's such a clever
coach he's just very very good that's
cool so so what's the plans for you um
for this season for this year
um
so i'm gonna go
to san diego and play three more big
tournaments there like the futures
province and then i'm trying to get my
ranking you know to like 400 500s by the
end of the year so i can start playing
like challenges
um and then from next year hopefully i
can keep just dragging my ranking down
to where i can be playing qualifying on
grand slams and
um that's the goal like my ranking
dropped a lot in the last
tours last tour in thailand which i was
very excited about um
and when you have that feeling of it
dropping um you just don't want to stop
you want to keep it rolling it's
exciting like seeing that ranking change
over and seeing you just like yes that's
that's pretty cool yeah how much did
covet affect you and um
your ranking and things like that
my golf got pretty good
i started playing unreal actually um
but tennis wise you're not ideal i was
just stuck here in new zealand and like
um we're lucky enough to have some
tournaments and stuff but it's not the
same as international you know even
like i was talking to a lot of uh the
people who mentor me around me and i was
like i just don't know you don't have
that plan or you don't have that hunger
to train because what are you training
for
um but of course everyone was in a
in a tough scenario but i think in new
zealand we were lucky
you know as much as people say we were
unlucky like we were safe and i think
that's the biggest thing you know um
i think i've had covert a couple times
but the tournaments don't tell you
because if they tell you you've got
covert then they have to shut the
tournament oh so
i'd be like real second they'll be like
yeah just yeah you haven't got covered
but stay in your room for a week just
like just stay in your room don't come
out
okay sweet no covert here
so
um yeah it's uh covered sucked man but
it is what it is again i gotta do some
things that i didn't you know i played
some summer soccer with my mates i was
like fizzing for a tuesday afternoon it
was like the most exciting time of my
week
and um
like golf just played a lot of golf got
pretty good
mate love that not the worst yeah so you
mentioned a little bit about trying to
get into the grand slams and getting
your ranking down to
um that level what level do you have to
be down to to start getting invited to
the to the big ones
around 200 so that i mean it looks like
a huge gap but it's like winning two
three big tournaments and you can start
cli getting dropping and dropping so it
can happen pretty quick but you also
have to play very very well um so it's
like getting entry so my ranking now can
get me entry into the a bit bigger
tournaments and gets you know to the
bigger tournaments where i can play and
there's more points on offer so it's
just about constantly improving and
again it's
you can focus on rankings and stuff but
i just try to focus as much as i can
like they're my goals but all my
processes and
stuff i can control do the rankings
change every game every tournament how
often do the rankings change every two
weeks is it oh yeah every two weeks yeah
so like if i made semi-finals then in
two weeks time the new rankings would
come out
so um
you also your rankings you have to
defend
what you had so say this today if i made
semi-finals last year and this year i'm
not playing i would lose those points
from that tournament because you have to
defend it every year whereas in golf
it's two years i think
so in tennis it's every year so it's
also about having consistency you could
have a great year
and then in december you're sitting
there like okay i gotta back it up
because if you don't back it up you're
back to square one yeah so freaking yeah
it's not not great
so
what about and sort of like a five-year
five-year goal what what's where do you
see yourself in sort of five years in
the tennis world
at five years i
wanna see myself inside the top hundred
that's where i wanna see myself i want
to see myself consistently playing
grand slams um
or
if not um
i'll be working at maryland's
supermarket and you plummet um
so
[Music]
yeah that's where i hope to see myself
in five years i mean i'm putting in the
work and i think
the last two years as
tougher as it is for me to say is the
years i've consistently put in the
correct work
um i used to think i was working hard
and doing the right work but i didn't
understand what correct work was so now
i feel like i'm doing the right things
on and off the court and holding myself
accountable for the little things off
court so
um i think i've got giving i'm giving
myself the best opportunity i love that
so what's the sort of dream age what's
the peak age
traditionally for a tennis player what
age do people feel like they're peaking
while in my head when i started playing
i thought i was going to be like living
it up when i was 13
but
that didn't exactly happen um
i think around 26 27 because i think
that's you know when you fully develop
not just physically but mentally
and
as tennis is such a mental sport like
you have to be so rock solid in the head
and you got to be a little bit like
insane
you got to be like
like you got to be different you know
you have to
[Music]
you have to be
yeah like if all those top guys are just
like
you know a little bit insane yeah like
even like djokovic and stuff the way
he is with things and like he only like
he never wears shoes like he goes out to
dinners and stuff barefoot says he wants
to connect himself to the earth i'm like
man i'll just wear my like shoes like
i'm good you know i'll i'd rather not
walk around barefoot but um
all these guys man they're just they
have their things and
you just gotta put in the work every day
and i think that's that's what it is so
um
yeah i think
yeah just gotta just gotta put in the
work uh it's not rocket science though
at the end of the day yeah i'm guessing
it's a massive sport for superstitions
you mentioned djokovic going out on bare
feet but i'd imagine there's heaps of
superstitions within the sport have you
got many
this is real weird but i used to have
this thing like in a warm up
i would say in my head if i don't hit
the shot over the net i'm not going to
win
so
if i like missed it i would like start
freaking out and have like a panic so
i'd have to like redo the shot
um i don't walk on lines after the
points finished
i like if you ever see me i don't walk
on a line
um
i have i have some random ones but
they're also real weird so i don't
really want to bring them up but there's
some real out the gate ones like i used
to
have to wear like the same hat if i won
a match oh yeah but then it got tough
like washing the same hat or even not
even washing it
so
um i mean you there's some guys with
random superstitions like there's this
guy played and he wrote like every match
he would write his game plan like on his
wrist yeah
so i would like walk past him and i'll
be like
when he got on your wrist there
like
there's i mean tennis players are just
weird i think in general we're a weird
kind
we're not normal honestly we're not
normal like that's what i'm saying
tennis player is a little bit insane
like you see on tour some guys like i
mean
this guy indian player travels with a
god and he puts a god on the side of his
core
and like you want to beat this guy but
then you walk past the god and you're
like hmm
look i don't really like how do you beat
that that's just too good you know like
you've got god on your side here
so
i i don't you know it's there's
there's there's yeah tennis are weirdos
man
they're just weird
yeah
and you mentioned uh
working at maryvale supermarket um what
are your plans life after tennis have
you got much other than the supermarket
dream
um
yeah i mean
when i was young i wanted to be a like
rubbish truck driver because of the
things they used to pull like i just
think that was awesome
um
but yeah now i want to i want to do
something with sales like i love talking
to people and
i love you know doing something i mean
doing like podcasts and stuff this this
type of stuff's awesome i reckon it's
sick um
but anything like that where i'm
interacting with people oh
um
i'll really like to do that um also like
helping
the younger generation in some way
i realized i don't know how to coach
i've tried helping a couple kids and i'm
pretty sure i made them worse so
i don't really know how to coach but i
wouldn't i wouldn't coach personally i
wouldn't coach tennis um
but yeah like sales or something like
that or just interacting with people and
that type of thing would be pretty cool
mate you'd run an awesome podcast i
reckon would derek and guys like um
djokovic and nadal and stuff would come
on if you ask them yeah but no one else
would be able to talk
i'd just be talking to myself and i'll
just be at the end of past like yeah
thanks for coming on
cheers that
like no one else will be able to get a
word so
i just like even if you see me playing i
like talk to myself
the whole time like people are probably
like is this guy got like someone else
on the court or like i'm having like
full-on conversations with myself
i told you i'm not lying with tennis or
weirdos we're not normal
what sort of stuff do you say to
yourself
oh honestly i just tell myself like try
to
tell myself to like compete and fight
and dig and like just try to like pump
myself up with like positivity um
there's one of the things my
psychologist worked on is like what you
say will take you closer to where you
want to go so
like
you know telling myself to like compete
and fight and like be a warrior out
there is like what i try to tell myself
now
whereas when i was 12 it's like you're
so bad
yeah the officer is so bad this is bad
that's bad i'm gonna miss this shot and
then you end up missing it and you're
like why am i missing it
so
um yeah i just count myself i just try
to be real positive i love that mate and
exciting times exciting times um coming
ahead for you looking forward to
following it but as always we have gone
to our instagram for some questions and
a few good necky lads look like they've
come in oh here we go um here but the
first question got this one twice
actually do you have any mentors or
people who help guide you
um
yup so i'm pretty
lucky when i was very young like reuben
um statham like i lived on his couch for
a year in auckland um
and uh
i was real lucky actually to be around
him because
someone who i looked up to and seeing
what he does and
he's one guy that has just maximized
everything out of his body and his
abilities as a tennis player he takes
care of the little things and he's one
guy that what you see on court is
so clear what he does off court is
beneficial for him and
you know like we'll be in the gym and
we'll finish and i'm like sweet done gym
session done and he'll be in there for
another 20 minutes doing something it
could be something little it could be
warming up you know doing something for
his forearms or something or his neck
strength like random but he just will
always put an extra effort and
that's when i learned that you know guys
like that there's a reason they get to
where they where they are
um
and then you know the rugby boys i'm
also lucky like
recently dan um has been helping me a
lot who's who's dan um carter oh dan
carr
no i've been pretty lucky like i saw him
at a
he was at this exhibition event
we did and he was playing like the
celebrity match and
he was like i think a bit nervous about
playing it and he he was actually pretty
good um
he was actually really bad but he was uh
he played and you know he did his
exhibition event then i saw him a few
times at next gen and he helped me out
with a lot of things and now if i have
any questions and stuff i need help with
around mindset he helps me out a lot
with it and
you know he's
he's he doesn't sugarcoat anything he
just gives me the exactly what i need to
do and i'm lucky i have people like him
and
like anton and you know bowden's helped
me a lot in the past and i'm just happy
i have guys like that around me who have
made it and especially in new zealand
where it's
i feel there's a lot of tall poppy
around yeah um
and guys like that copper you know if i
think i have pressure imagine missing a
kick or dropping a ball with them for a
test you know even i think they're
horrible people after that but um
you know like having those guys around
me they're just
they're good people before
good athletes and that's what they've
taught me is that tennis and myself
they're two separate things and
they're just
they help me like you know like big
brothers type of thing they're just
really good to me and
i've just you know
they kind of tell me what's coming
around the corner before it even is
there so i kind of know what to expect
and you know i've made plenty of
mistakes in in the past but i'm lucky i
have
you know people like them to hold me
accountable like my older brother who's
you know like one person i lean on a lot
for support and
yeah i just think it's um
it's pretty cool having people like that
around you how good is that couple of
the rugby legs helping out new zealand's
best tennis player yeah yeah it's cool
but that goes on to this next question
actually um tell us the story about the
first time you met body
um
so i was at asb classic i think i was
like 17 i was young and i was heading
with um
uh john isner he got me to like hit with
him for the week through prince
sponsoring me
and um i was heading on like the outdoor
court on asb classic uh it's like court
two but it's like there's bleachers so
the bleachers were packed and
i don't know what bowdoin was doing but
i think he was up at the heineken lounge
or something no yeah and yeah of course
he was and um
i saw him up there but he was just
looking through the cage like minding
his own and i saw him up there because
i'm like i wonder a lot when i when i
play like i'm looking everywhere and
i saw him and i'm like oh this like i'm
not that's beautiful like you know i'm
17 years old i'm from taranaki like you
know you want to meet this guy but i'm
like nah like i'm meant to be training
with john isner at the same time and
he's got like his coach and his agent
and agents looking at signing me and
i've got all this happening and i just
like
they're talking and i just look up i'm
like oh my god it's bowden barrett and
i'm like yelling out at him and he's
like look he's like oh my god who was
this kid and i'm like
come down here and i got him down and he
came down and um
you know i talked to him for a bit and
then i just started pissing him all the
time to help me and stuff and he was
just the kindest of guys and
he just helped me out heaps and like
before i play matches i'd be nervous and
you'd send me a paragraph on stuff to
work on and all those guys man they're
not like
now you realize it's actually not that
they're good athletes they're just good
people they're like they just want me to
do
well for me being me not me to be a good
tennis player they just want me to be
happy
and
all these guys like as well i don't
really see too much of the rugby and
stuff anymore overseas the time
difference and stuff but you know they i
just want those guys are just good
people and i just want them to be happy
honestly so i probably i've apologized
to him a couple times about how my
behavior was during that period but
um
yeah sure to shoot me
he is a lad and he is
awesome to hear he's keen to help out
but
does not surprise me okay next thing is
it true they call you the sailor new
girl at every port
um no i'm allergic to water surpass
i'm a focus man i'm dialed in on the
tennis
i'm dialed in you don't have time for
that you know i focus focus
i'm not i'm not uh but he's all wifed up
i don't know he's all wifed up so he's
putting all this external nonsense onto
other people
that's actually pretty funny jealous
yeah he's just jealous man you want he
wants to be me
how good he's a good fella also he's a
good he's a good fella
maybe where's that man that man wears
his wears is hard on his sleeve
he wears his heart honestly he's a good
he's all from the necky i mean yeah
there's something about it up there
right that's how we are for sure okay
next one toughest thing about pro tennis
i would say
dealing with you get 10 high for a 90
low
like
you might get highs a couple times
during the year but you deal with a lot
of lows and
i probably didn't deal with that that
well last year but now i'm starting to
understand that every time there's a low
there's a chance to grow and there's a
chance to improve as you know cheesy as
that sounds yeah um
but yeah i think that's the hardest
thing it's consistency and being alone
and just how tough it is
you know the highs and the lows but you
get to travel the world and see some
incredible places and
incredible people and
incredible girls and um
i think that's um i think that's all all
part of it so you just got to look at
the positives but
i think that's the toughest part is the
10 percent you know 10 percent highs for
the 90 lows
the sailor i love that from you okay
next one
who's your dream
golf foursome my dream golf
awesome um
dream golf foursome
i would say
who can i come up with that's not like
that would just have unreal chat on the
golf course
michael jordan man oh michael jordan
yeah
michael jordan
uh rafael nadal oh yeah
nice
um
lance armstrong because i want to know
if nadal's juicing
and i think he would know
um
and then of course tiger woods man that
guy like
tiger woods i mean what a foursome there
he was a sailor yeah he was a sailor
mate he was a sailor he played in a lot
of foursomes didn't he
he donald trump maybe actually
just someone just real controversial i
just want to like
you don't want to play with like do the
part you don't want to play with just
like four boring people you know
um yeah
yeah nah
yeah that's probably my favorite golf
enforcing i'd say
have you come across rafael nadal much
when i was younger i did um
but not re i mean though he's been at
the top of the grand slams and injured
and whatnot but
um i got actually invited to train with
him
um at the nadal academy um
but happen to
uh have to come home due to covert
lockdowns so in isolation
so
cheers cheers for that um but yeah
um
yeah those guys man they're just
different level like you watch them and
it's like their highest levels here and
their lowest levels here and that's the
difference is that
you know other guys could be highest
levels there but then their lowest
levels here so they just beat you here
every time
they just
i mean how many times can you say you've
seen djokovic play horrendous or bad you
just can't he doesn't
you know he just doesn't
other guys might play well but he never
plays bad oh interesting who is the best
tennis player of all time that one's
here too
best tennis player of all time
see this is a tough one but i
i don't like
i i personally don't i respect djokovic
a lot but i don't i don't you know like
the way he is i guess it's some of the
things he does
but i would say djokovic i mean on stats
you have to
you have to say djokovic like people say
federer people say nadal but djokovic
beats every single stat
so
that's not a popularity contest who's
the greatest tennis player of all time
and i think it is djokovic oh huge who
do you think who do you think i'm going
to go with you djokovic
you have on stats you hit you have to eh
good call good cool i'll come back
no honestly i don't know the stats and i
would have been leaning towards like a
federer probably but um yeah yeah he's
the billboard of tennis he's the
billboard of tennis fedor is the
billboard of tennis
like when you think of a perfect tennis
player perfect gentleman
elegant tennis player sponsored by nike
all of that stuff you think of federer i
mean
he's sponsored by nike mercedes and
rolex i mean how can you hate him
come on how can you hate him like i
would still go for a g-shock any day of
the week but i mean you just can't hate
the guy so
but then djokovic on stats has just
beaten all those guys more times he's
you know nadal has got more grand slams
though so
you could go with him
um
i got reuben statham there you go
oh well for the greats anyway
okay next question if you could get a
video shout out from any celebrity who
would it be and why this questions come
from our major sponsor swish
man i just
i don't know i i think like michael
jordan man yeah i thought it would be
one of your golf golfing buddies yeah
michael jordan or kanye
i reckon kanye would be sick
that and i've got a yeezy for president
shirt that i'd wear oh to respond to his
video he sends me that he won't reply to
but i reckon that would be incredible
like kanye or michael jordan would be
sick like that like those options yeah
yeah what are your hobbies outside
tennis um golf
um i love golf like i play uh with i
have a group of mates i play with like
um
uh back home and i go out with them um
so go play golf all the time what's your
handicap i'm playing off like a nine but
that's because i into good scorecards so
i don't know what every time i have like
four bad holes i ditch the scorecard so
um that's not an honest score but i can
play all right it's just i come back
with a slice or a hook every time so i
have to manage it
so nothing come i'm not consistent no
you're not a djokovic no i'm not a jock
fish on the goalkeeper
um
i mean geordie is an he's a ridiculous
golfer incredible um he's a freak like
he
uh yeah um he's a gun but like guys like
that i don't know i mean they just
talented they can just do it whereas me
i play with a group of uh four of my
mates or three of my mates back home and
we're just hackers we just go out and
have fun and it's been to you know like
um
because one of my mates cole hareb he's
probably the most horrendous golfer of
all time like the most
terrible swing and somehow lose to him
sometimes so
i mean that's it's just banter on the
course and it's just good fun to get out
and
be out with your mates and you know have
some fun
and fortnite fortnite oh
yeah there's my because when i'm when
i'm traveling i just take my xbox and i
can just plug it in and still play with
my mates so
yeah fortnight nice okay two more to go
um
i want to know about the
party scene of tennis is it do they have
after parties after a tournament what's
the what's the night life like after a
tennis tournament or do they all just go
to their room and focus on the next
tournament absolutely not i don't think
people realize like
they see tennis players focus and stuff
but there's a build up of like
steam that needs to be lit off there and
there's
i mean parties
girls i mean that's that's just how it
is it's just like normally what happens
is if you lose in the quarter finals you
find the other three losers from that
day and you guys just have like a you go
out with the losers and um
or if you win the tournament you know it
also depends like normally it's at the
end of a tour because you don't want to
do it like party during the week and
stuff like that um or during another
tournament you only got two days to the
next one yeah um
so you know i you gotta you gotta pick
your battles um
but tennis players they're
loose units bunch of weird loose units
so
um
yeah it's it's probably not the
consistency of some other athletes or
some other sports of where it's like
every weekend type of stuff
um
but when they go out they i mean you're
losing a tournament you're in mexico
you're not going to go to your hotel
room
like you're in barcelona you lose what
are you going to do you hit it right i'm
not going to my room like
you know it's you're going to go
experience and have some fun and let l
you know live a little so like we lost
and oh when we won in vegas that was a
pretty cool night um
we had davis cup in vegas and i hadn't
seen the strip the whole week because
we'd been like dialed in and you know
we'd been at the courts and stuff like
that and training
then after we won
i mean the coaches don't want to know us
so they're just like see you later like
have the team dinner and you're off so i
went out and
i was so gutted i didn't see the strip
so about about 2 a.m i was just running
through vegas with my phone taking
photos of everything i could find yeah
and then the next morning i'm like felt
like i kind of lived the strip a little
bit so that was kind of cool but um
i actually met up with like uh
ufc fighters there was this guy kevin
holland yeah and um ended up like with
him and ufc fighters and stuff and
um it was pretty fun vegas is vegas but
a week was too long i wouldn't want to
play davis cup there again
but if you're not playing davis cup
you're in charge of your own rules you
can go out when you want you don't have
like a manager or something like a rugby
team where you've got curfews and things
like that it's all on you yeah exactly
and you don't have to i mean
tennis exactly it's on you you've but
you've also got sponsors that yeah
expect results and you've got to hit
targets and if you don't hit targets
you don't get that sponsor anymore so
it's like it's also a bit tough in that
sense where
you know
you're kind of the captain of your own
shirt but
there's people paying for that [ __ ] so
you've got to have the respect for them
that you know you pick and choose when
you want to go out and do stuff and
party and stuff but at the end of the
day we're professionals and we're here
to play sport and here to win tennis
matches
but you also
you can't spend the whole year just
dialing into tennis every single day
you've got to have
you know time when you
relax and let loose a little bit but
that's maybe four or five days of the
year yeah
so anyone who's listening i don't want
you thinking that we just go out every
single weekend because we do not
it is not like that
yeah exactly five days sounds like good
stuff exactly yeah okay last question
ask every guest this one best piece of
advice you have for a wider led listener
uh when
you're playing any sport the best piece
of advice i've had is like when you're
playing a sport always try to do the
right things because when or lose you
come off the field or caught improving
and i think
that's probably the best
piece of advice because if you think
about it if you
you know throw toys out of the car don't
focus on what you need to do and have a
bad day everyone's going to have bad
days but you don't try to get the best
out of that bad day you might come off
losing and having
a terrible you know time as well like
you don't improve yeah so i think that's
it is trying to focus on the process and
trying to improve
love it i knew you'd have a good piece
of advice so inspirational man my tennis
game is going to develop very quickly
yeah i see it see it the classic see the
classic in january
oh if i could move my hip's still
staggered but if maybe i could play
doubles half the chord yeah let's do it
i think maybe mike venus is looking for
a new partner
send him a message get up get up get him
on the potty cinematic
oh mate well it's been a pleasure um
having a yarn with you mate um hell of a
lad awesome journey awesome to get an
insight into life as a tennis player and
hear how weird some of these characters
are and um we're really looking forward
to following your career and your what
you what your pathway holds over the
next few years and
seeing you become world number one
appreciate it mate go well thanks for
having me you're a lad